e aí é que se chama canal tudo bem com
vocês olha só eu estou nesse momento
apartamento no rio de janeiro eu comprei
comprei também essa pakita quando ataque
registrado aqui com naiara pode falar
que estamos aqui para um vídeo bem
interessante em poucas vezes eu fiz ou
nunca vou te chamar de mulher
hoje ela vai transformar uma mulher
vocês fala meu deus a mulher demora
tanto para sair do banheiro demora tanto
para fazer a maquiagem que você não
entende o universo feminino a gente vai
ter que ser namorada fala tá bom já sei
que sua família vai demorar a minha mãe
a seu trabalho possa prazo legal
cirurgia bater rima clicar na setinha
sua aqui meu nome é que eu sou câmera -
outubro enquanto o olho no olho aqui a
galera que quando eu abri vai da azul e
um de massa correira da época pode botar
cerâmica eu digo que eu já não tinha
barba agora só isso aqui é pronta calor
foi condenado a 51 12 anos gosta das
coisas é que os vídeos não tinha muito
importante é um passo essencial de morta
e voice em cinco anos
bush que fala a língua eu estava me
apoiando
vem agora fazer o contorno para a final
onde era de biscoito prática exata já o
stoke início ela estão assim o dólar foi
afinal exato é e na conseqüente
brilhando ensinar a quem tem que ser
valorizada
agora vamos para sonda aquela ficção
disse ó silva passar o batom e kamui
agora moro onde os vinhos mora no
condomínio
ele quer saber realmente o que o senhor
eu vou fazendo careta quando toma aqui
no brasil você como é que é
a gente tem que saber e agora a ficar
lindo marrom com um mac com o carro
tomando como qualquer outro lado do
brasil é assim
já qual é o meu único a segunda neste
ano enquanto no jornal como perdeu seu
olho esquerdo não espera chega em meio a
pressões e 15
não é porque tenho dificuldade em abrir
um horizonte pode abrir um outro aliado
o outro nome mencionado pela primeira
vez
não temos um bloco de 29 blocos o bloco
pega o boa
agora deixem em paz e limpa assim sai
pra não falar assim
assim é o batom que vai fazer minha
cabeça
o interessante da sua máquina
agora só vai aqui da ilha é agora fiquei
maravilhado quer dizer que não tem nada
a ver com a gente agora está aí o cara
de gente falando nela
olha aí galera curtindo a vida está aqui
agora tentando ir à onu não conseguiu
galera o seguinte galera você vira o boi
vai trabalho de na área atacassem pode
clicar aqui ou neste link ele não olha a
aparecer no rosto dela para se inscrever
no canal dela e se você vai gostar do
vice já sabe é deixar aquele boi gostei
aqui vai ajudar demais não vai ser assim
também não queria dizer que também
queria dizer que agora tem um site olha
que beleza ele está aparecendo aqui ou
na escrita aqui na despesa não é que tá
aparecendo no vídeo - isso é só digitar
la na sua caixa de endereços
aí que fica no céu é navegador ou seab
abrir o website da honeywell da ponta o
inglês um ponto com ponto br vai gostar
desse vídeo por favor deixa eu gostei é
muito importante pra mim e pra não se
inscreve no canal e também vai lá no
facebook onde eu postei de novo na cut e
marcas suas amigas a poder elas verem a
boi para maquiagem era é e no canal dela
vai sair um outro vídeo também eu
maqueano ela então se estiver lá e ficar
atento é nós comenta que achou do vídeo
meu amigo acabam nunca né não aqui na
fazenda bela maquiagem noite muito
obrigado a desistir até aqui
valeu